yeah so i guess if you
if you have a question
then just shout as loud as you can
but there's also this mic
so if you wave at me i'll i'll run the
mic over to you
uh if you don't feel comfortable
shouting
sounds like a good compromise okay let's
let's just get uh started i think i
think it's uh time
okay so we're really really delighted to
have luca travis on delivering some
lectures in our boot camp where
i personally am extremely sad that he
couldn't be here
in real life but
we'll take what we can get and so
uh
luca i'm handing it off to you
go ahead
thank you so the
the lectures that i've prepared for the
for these four hours are on a
computational complexity theory of
average case complexity of
algorithms
and the
set of topics that i
hope to cover
are to
well i just very briefly discuss
what it even means exactly to talk about
the average case complexity of problems
so
what is the distribution problem and
what are
various not entirely equivalent notions
of what it means for an algorithm to be
average case efficient
then we will see how the standard tools
of cooperation complexity have been
brought to bear
on the study of the average case
complexity of problems
so
then those tools are reductions and
completeness like is it possible to show
that at least
if
some problem is hard on average then
some other problem also is and then
construct the chain of reductions as
we have done for the study of
anti-completeness or
hardness of approximation
so here are the definitions of exactly
how reductions work are also a little
bit
subtle because you can want to make sure
even algorithm that makes mistakes or
runs in very long time on some small
probability set
can be used to uh solve some
different problem
so then we will see
actually the existence of complete
problems in the sense that
there are very specific problems that
under the uniform distribution if you
can solve them efficiently under any of
the notions that we will talk about then
pretty much everything can be done like
every
filter system can be broken every
um
[Music]
every throwing np under any reasonable
distribution can be sold efficiently and
so on
and then discuss some uh final points
where i think uh
like even the if the results are a bit
technical
and sort of narrow the
techniques by which they're proved are
kind of interesting
so we will see that in
arguing about these completeness results
an important role is played by
data compression
they sort of to reduce control under a
generic distribution to some other
problem under the uniform distribution
what energy you want to do is to
compress the input because data
compression will take you from a genetic
distribution to an almost uniform
distribution
and that
when you want to do that with
distributions for which you don't know
how to do optimal compression something
similar can be done with
hashing
now
in
unsupervised machine learning that is
completely unrelated to
any of this
an important task is feature discovery
for uh
some data that comes from certain
distributions
and it
seems that somehow it's well understood
that
feature discovery and
unsupervised machine learning is closely
related to
compression
and that sort of one you really don't
know what to do looking at random
features
can be
helpful so random features cannot
correspond to hashing
and then there is more than a
superficial
connection there between kind of what is
done to do reductions between problems
and for what is done to analyze data
coming from certain distributions
and so kind of even though it's a bit
difficult to have a
dialogue
at this distance
maybe when we get to that point i hope
there will be
questions and
discussions
and then
so finally
um also
talking about why
many of the things one actually would
like to
prove that would like to uh
lecture on in
in a course like this are
all open problems
and what that seems to be some really
significant bottleneck in
applying this framework of reductions
and completeness to the study of uh
average case problems that somehow
when we're studying people greatness or
hardness or approximation
we see ultimately all the problems are
equivalent like all in three complete
problems are
equivalent uh all
approximating
i don't know max result better than
seven eight is equivalent to uh
approximating max click better than and
to the point nine nine because it won't
probably get the other
but when it comes to average case
complexity it seems like different
problems are hard for different reasons
and so that it isn't really possible to
introduce them one to the other
okay so most of what i will talk about
today will be the
definition of efficiency for
average case complexity notions of
reductions between problems
and
how to get completeness results
and
the reference for all of this it's a
paper by
levin that appeared in stock 1984
which is shown here and what i'm showing
is not the first page of the paper but
it's the paper
like the
this was a one-page paper with no
references
which contained stuff that took the
community a lot of time
and a lot of 50 page long papers to kind
of digest and
reconstruct
so then later
let me publish a full version of this
paper in cycle which was two pages long
and uh according to legend i don't know
if the story is true but it's all good
enough even if it's false
the editor said well this paper is great
we ought to accept it but it should be
at least four times longer
and then levin sent back a revision
which was
four copies of the same paper stapled
together
okay
so um
so
so this is a skip from the beginning the
kind of problems that we want to
talk about are
problems that come with a distribution
of inputs that for
the sake of all these four hours we
always assume it's a known distribution
so there's a problem with a
known distribution
and actually um
whenever i talk about the distribution
of inputs what they actually mean it's a
collection of distributions
one distribution for every input length
whatever
input length means in
for each particular problem maybe not
literally the number of bits it takes to
write an instance but some
size parameter that makes sense for the
problem and maybe if we're talking about
graphs
we have one distribution for each n and
it's a distribution of a graph with n
vertices or if we are
talking about uh
uh
n by n by n tensors again it will be one
distribution for every n where n is the
size of each dimension
and so here are some problems that
maybe we like to apply this theory to uh
perhaps planted clique where n is the
number of vertices
or
a random trees out with a certain fixed
density of clauses
where n might be the number of
variables
and by the way we'll see kind of
different problems will come with
somewhat different notions of what it
means for an algorithm to be
a good knowledge
like say for the random threesome below
the threshold
what we would like an algorithm to do is
to
find a satisfying assignment
almost always since we know that one
exists almost always
for random formula above the threshold
what we would like is to
find some kind of certificate about
satisfiability almost always since we
know that the formula will be
unsatisfiable almost always
um
or maybe we are interested in problem
solving like a
numerical flavor or literal algebraic or
maybe also problems in photography all
of them come with some definition of
what we want to do that's the problem
and some
description of what the inputs look look
like which is the ensemble of
distributions
okay so let's say now
discuss what it means for an algorithm
to be
efficient since it's a surprisingly
subtle issue and there are a couple of
possible definitions
neither of which is the first definition
that would come to mind
okay so let's say we have some problem
uh
p
and there is some ensemble of
distributions let's just call it a
distribution over inputs
and we have some
algorithm
and for now let's think about algorithms
that actually are
always right but are sometimes slow
and uh let's give some name something
like t a of x it's the
time of uh a on input x
so since we are talking about average
case analysis of algorithms perhaps the
most natural definition
is to look at what is the
expectation for a random input of
length n
of the running time of the algorithm on
input x
and we might say that if
this is less than
some polynomial in n
then the algorithm
is
a average case polynomial
so this definition uh actually some
so
as some um
shortcoming
uh
in particular
so this might seem like really a weird
concern but
so bear with me
so one concern is that um
it's possible for a
an algorithm to be
polynomial in expectation
even though
some other algorithm that is
consistently as a running time that is
maybe quadratic or any way polynomial in
the previous one
it's not
so imagine that we have a
so imagine that a is the following
behavior that um
that with probability
like maybe like there is a uniform
distribution there is one input on which
the running time is very high
and then on all the other inputs
the running time is i don't know n
square
so then the expectation of the
running time will be something like
essentially n squared
but now imagine you have some
other algorithm that has the
running time that is
quadratic
in the running time of hey so then now
the expected running time of uh
of this new algorithm which is really
just quadratic in the right time of a
this is exponential
and
click the comment
comment like this
alright so why is this a shortcoming of
the definition
uh
well
we so first of all um
although this seems like a really
strange corner case
if you're talking about algorithms that
are always correct and it works on np
complete problems
uh we believe that there will have to be
inputs on which running time is
exponential
and if it happens that the expected line
time is small that will be perhaps
because these exponential in time inputs
have exponentially small probability
but then it actually be true that some
sufficiently large power of the running
time of our algorithm will
uh
exponential expectation
so in fact this is not a corner case but
it's so the typical behavior of the
distribution of running times of
algorithms are always correct for np
complete problems
you know since we're going to talk about
so reductions from one point to another
that might change the input length
uh might require the simulation of some
other algorithm with some kind of
slowdown
it's not it's not out of the
question that we might uh end up with
issues where
um we have some algorithm that really
believes
we want to think of as being efficient
now we do some transformation
we get a new algorithm for a new problem
through a reduction
this new algorithm has a function of its
running time it's quadratically
slower somehow quadratic in something
efficient should also be efficient but
this definition doesn't
allow it
so this
kind of
concern
in mind
uh this is the definition given by
living which is a broader definition
like it allows to be an algorithm to be
called efficient even if its expectation
is not polynomial
so definition given 11 is that
a is
average case polynomial
maybe he said polynomial on average
if there is a constant c
such that the
expectation of
a root
a seed root of
the run time is linear
so let's uh
sort of
this was the one i think said in one
line in that one page paper that was a
bit uh
mystifying
actually it was even stranger than this
because
instead of talking about the collection
of distributions he actually had just
one distribution overall inputs you also
the first peak your input length and
then
pick an input of that length
so in this definition you were just
picking an input from this single
distribution
then you were looking at some root of
its running time dividing it by n
there is no n so you would be dividing
it by the length of x
and then you wanted this to be finite
so that was how
he presented things
so
so what are the advantages of this
definition
so first of all
if
if we have an algorithm that satisfies
the more reasonable definition
then
by convexity
it also
satisfies levin's definition
so we are sort of capturing
all the algorithms whose expertise in
time is polynomial
in addition
if
if a and b are
two algorithms such that
one is quadratic in the other letter in
time of b is always
during time of a squared
and
a
satisfies this definition
then
b will also satisfy this definition with
just a bigger constant
and in fact other
robustness properties will be
true for uh this definition if you
like change the size of the input by
adding other things
uh you're not messing up the calculation
okay yeah this is sam from the audience
what why n instead of
n squared or root n or something like it
seems like if you mess with the constant
c you can
the definition would be the same if you
put any polynomial in n on the right
hand side is that right
it's right uh there isn't
so just
a you also fix a convention or you could
just say there is some constant such
that the whole expression is at most a
polynomial
by requiring just order of n on the
other side
the root that you're taking the inverse
of that you can think of the
exponent of your expected polynomial
like if
the expectation of your running time
to the power of one over c is linear you
can think of your running time as being
kind of and to the same
so some of the constant c as this kind
of meaning if you put order over n on
the right but
um
that's probably even that's probably
even formalizable right like with you
know with probability point nine nine
you have running time at most end to the
c or something like that if you throw
all your inputs
exactly so uh so now we'll get to
another nice property of uh
of this uh definition
which is that okay so suppose now we
have
a 11 efficient
algorithm
okay so now uh as someone was saying we
can use markov's inequality and then say
that the
probability
that
the running time is bigger than some
value
now we can take roots on both sides then
take a
markers inequality
uh and so yeah we get something like
this so for example the probability
that
the running time
is bigger than
i don't know and to decay
it's smaller than
order of n over n to the
k over c
so it's order of 1 over n to the
k over c minus one
so when you whenever you're looking at
an exponent
bigger than c
you get
a
small probability of getting a running
time bigger than and to that exponent
but sort of the tail of the running time
of the algorithm
at least obeys a power law
typically
things will be much sharper like usually
running times are much more concentrated
but just the definition guarantees that
there is this kind of uh
no worse than power law
tail of the running time of the
algorithm
yeah sure
uh
that definition was in terms of
expectation of the one over c of the
running time would not capture a
situation where you still have
exponentially large running time on
polynomial exceptions
yes so in fact there are a number of
cases where
we would kind of like to say that an
algorithm is efficient
but this definition would say
that it isn't
so for example
so basically whenever you don't get this
kind of tail
so say that
maybe with the
probability
maybe there is like one input
uh
the running time
is
uh
exponential but like
two to the n square then there is no way
of
getting this definition to be satisfied
even though
we will never see this input because
it's so unlikely or even
um
now there is some negligible probability
of
an exponential running time this is
always not allowed by the
definition
uh so that's definitely um
well definitely
it's a
uh
well the so definition says that the
algorithms with this kind of behavior
are
never efficient uh
in some cases we would like to think of
them as being efficient so that's a
limitation of the definition that
doesn't
capture cases like this
however
an advantage of the
definition is that it has a very
clean
characterization and
the characterization is the
is the following
and maybe let's first look at it from
one direction
those things
probably
levin thought they were all obvious but
they were pointed out
by russell in palliative uh that
sort of wrote
a preview that will refer to
uh oscillator that had lots of
interesting to say about average case
complexity
so the characterization is the following
so here now we're thinking about
algorithms that are always right
but sometimes they take a very long time
now something that is done
and sort of we
do have algorithms like this maybe they
do some kind of
[Music]
branch and bound or restrict
kind of guided search
and there will be inputs on which they
keep going and take a really really long
time to converge even though on lots of
other inputs they are
more efficient
and what we do with algorithms
this type is that if they really take a
long time
we will not be able to run them to
completion so we will impose some kind
of
timeout
and you can see the formula that i wrote
here as saying
what kind of
trade-off we can expect for a timeout
like if we set the timeout at time and
to decay
we are guaranteed that the fraction of
inputs that
will
cause a timeout or the probability
measure of the inputs that will cause
that amount to arise is
at most this much
so in particular
we could
say the following like
a t
like what is a t such that
the probability of
exceeding
a running time of t
is
less than epsilon
but we can
kind of
plug it in we want
epsilon to be
order of n divided by and to the
k over c
so
sorry
i have a t to the
one over c so basically t needs to be
n over epsilon to the same
just needs to be polynomial in another
episode
so if
so if an algorithm is
is efficient
definition
create algorithm a
then it can be modified
into an algorithm a prime that takes two
inputs
uh input x and an input epsilon
such that
this algorithm
either outputs
the correct answer
or times out
and the probability that
it doesn't output the
correct answer
is less than epsilon
and running time
is polynomial
in
n over epsilon
where n is the
size of the input
so an algorithm that is
so efficient according to 11 can be
transformed into an algorithm that has
always polynomial running time
polynomial in the input and in some kind
of
accuracy parameter
and
the probability
according to the distribution of inputs
that it fails to provide the correct
answer is at most the accuracy parameter
so if you're familiar with approximation
algorithms this is a bit like a
p task
except that the approximation here
instead of being
so how close to the optimum you are it's
how often you're able to produce a
correct answer
so the interesting thing is that this is
a characterization like
if you have an algorithm that has this
kind of behavior
that you give it an input of your
problem you give it an accuracy
parameter
runs in time polynomial in the size of
the input and the inverse of the
accuracy parameter
and except with
probability at most accuracy parameter
will get you the correct answer if you
have
this sort of
average case algorithm scheme
you can transform it into an algorithm
that is efficient according to 11.
so
suppose we have
some algorithm
a prime
such that
given input and an epsilon it runs in
polynomial time
in and over epsilon
either
either outputs the correct answer
or it outputs some kind of
fail
output
and the probability of
failing is at most epsilon
then we can
develop
an algorithm
a that is efficient according to 11.
so what yeah if you if you look at the
sort of algorithms in the in the book
like the you know the average case
algorithms we know and love like
spectral algorithms on random graphs or
uh
mcmc sampling for
sparse random three set formulas or
something like are are they all
efficient by this definition like is it
capturing the kind of things we
intuitively
write as efficient average case
algorithms or are there exceptions
that we think of as we still want to say
our efficient you know concrete
algorithms for concrete problems that we
like
well the thing is that often we don't uh
analyze tail of the distribution right
so we say um
you know except with polynomially
small probability we cannot get the
right answer
now if
if you can say you know i have running
time that is polynomial
except with exponentially small
probability
then for sure you are
satisfying this definition
if your running time is
polynomial it can accept with normally
small probability then
you would really have to look a bit more
into exactly what is the
the trade-off like
how long would it take to get a
smaller probability
also
there is another issue that
actually there are multiple issues
um
so one is that
i'll do in a minute i will give a
different definition but
this definition talks about algorithms
that
never make a mistake
or kind of the worst thing they can do
is to give up at a certain point
but for many of the algorithms that you
uh suddenly that's not necessarily
what's happening like maybe the
algorithm always gives some kind of
answer
sometimes the answer is totally off but
it's not able to tell when the answer is
good and
when it isn't
so
you know we often write algorithms for
reputation problems and those those we
require always right so that at least
that part of the definition fits right
there
the refutation algorithms
if you think of failing to find the
refutation as kind of failing in this
sense
then they
satisfy
they would satisfy this definition
provided that
you would be able to analyze the tail of
the distribution
so to say well if i go to
higher and higher degree of sum of
squares or
whatever approach i'm using
how much am i
decreasing the probability of
failing
and do i ever get to the point where
i am
never failing like i'm refuting all the
unsatisfiable formulas
and
sort of
is the probability of failing always
polynomial in the
in the running time
i say if you do sum of square carelessly
you
you maybe get something like running
time and choose k
sorry
you get any time n to the k but the
probability is more like one over n
choose k and kind of eventually you have
this n to them versus two to them
which are not polynomial in uh one
another
so what would be wrong with a definition
that more closely follows the kind of
algorithmic guarantees we're used to
writing where we just say
uh you know with probability at least
one minus
a tiny polynomial
the algorithm does well and that's the
end of the story
that um it's trickier to get reductions
that preserve
this notion of
tractability
because if you
so as we'll see later to cannot get any
hope of making reductions work
the
probability of failing
should be
negligible in the sense of the word as
in
cryptography that somehow
you can bond it by any polynomial that
you want
so here we could write we could write i
mean very often in our algorithms sorry
there's nothing too much of attention
but we can we can
often write our algorithms papers like
that but it doesn't have to be
exponentially small right if you want
reductions where you compose polynomial
time algorithms polynomially many times
like failure probability
uh one over n to the log n
would be yes right exactly i don't know
i tolerated by this definition this
really requires exponentially small
failure probability
yes so um
in fact maybe
uh
i i thought about doing things a
different way to so the first describe
what the reductions look like
and then work backwards what reasonable
definition of tractability
uh those reductions preserve
because that's exactly because that's
really the way things happen that
i'm assuming that's 11 the reduction in
mind
and then he came up with the definition
that kind of disruptions would uh work
well with
so if our definition of tractability is
the alkaline runs in fixed polynomial
time and that's actually the definition
most often used in cryptography
the different the the algorithm runs in
fixed polynomial running time
the probability of failure is negligible
meaning it goes to zero faster than the
inverse of any polynomial
then this definition is fine like it's
preserved by the reductions
and
it's robust in
in many ways
and it definitely
um
is a closer match to
what we usually call
tractability when we
analyze algorithms
okay
i like that definition more thank you
all right so um
so regarding this definition uh you sort
of wanted to argue this characterization
so
so remember we
let's start we said that if something
had this
root of a running time
being linear in expectation
then you can change it into an algorithm
that has fixed polynomial time
and inverse polynomial
probability of failure
and
the converse holds in the sense that if
you have an algorithm that has
fixed polynomial in time
inverse polynomial probability of
failure you can trade off the
probability of failure with your running
time
and then you can get an algorithm that
is always right
and that has
living type
efficiency
and the way you would
do that is to just
you run
so given an input x
you write with some fixed value of
epsilon if it fails you try a smaller
epsilon
if it fails
you try an even smaller epsilon and so
on
you let them decrease expansion
so
so this is
this is an algorithm that is
always right
and as
variable
running time
what is
the let's say
what
um
well when you uh
look at the running time of uh this
algorithm well
um
it always runs a prime once
and so it has whatever is the running
time of
uh a prime
it
with probability at most one quarter it
runs it again
you probably at most one eight it runs
it again and so on so
uh guess you have to
okay so the first time it was
n over epsilon to the c
so
it's 2 n to the c
to the 1 over 2 c
so then we probably at most
a half it fails
and now we run it with
now n over epsilon is foreign
okay maybe i need the
three here
we probably one quarter it fails twice
and then we have to run it with
parameter eight
so basically in this calculation we get
n
times the summation of
this is like one over
yeah so you get some kind of uh
i think with one third works you get a
kind of geometric series
that uh has an exponent smaller than
one
i guess what
it's uh
two the k plus one to the one third
divided by two to the k
it goes down exponentially in k
and so
this is
order of uh and to the one over to the c
and that's smaller than order one
but apart from the calculation which i
think it's right with 99 percent
probability but
the
the point that arguably just that if you
have this
kind of average case approximation
scheme
where you can get small smaller fuel
probability with high and higher running
time you can convert it into an
algorithm that is always right just by
trying again and again with smaller and
smaller
epsilon parameters
and that will satisfy its definition
uh
okay
now that we have uh
this characterization
area
was there a question
is
i'm sorry uh hello yeah i guess i'm
trying to ask in the first inequality
why there's expectation or just a typo
uh so in the first inequality
uh like the right hand side sorry i
meant
ah sorry yeah yeah
thanks and also i want to clarify are
you assuming that you try these
algorithms multiple times the failing
are independent so that's why you get
104 for the second failure
no it's not that they're independent
um
so i uh
yes i'm first using complexity to get
the exponent uh
out of the sum and the unit of
expectation to
divide the tries
but the
the point is that
the
probative on a random x that i
say i go to the third try
it's one quarter
because i need to have
this this has to be one of the axes
for which the would fail with parameter
one quarter at at most one quarter of
them fail
it also has to be one of those that fail
with when the parameter is a half
and
those events need not to be contained
one another
but you can still upper bound the
probability that
it fails the first two cases by
one quarter
yeah so
when i do this multiple tries
i
always decrease the second parameter
so
an input x for which i have failed the
first two times
in particular failed the previous time
and the probability mass of the axis
that failed here is at most one quarter
by the way i defined the behavior of
this algorithm
okay i'm
trying to
work out my head the the weaker
guarantees you said don't satisfy this
definition when you had
a uh
one over n to the log n probability of
having exponential uh to the running
time or one number you know how would
they look like in this view that
translate into a
weak super polynomial dependence on
epsilon or how
like
in that case you would even have
exponential dependency on epsilon at
some point
right because if
say that the way your
distribution of running times look like
is that with probability 1 over n to the
log n
your running time is exponential
then if you want epsilon to be less than
one over n to the log n
you need to allow in that case the
running time to be exponential
and then true then as a function of n to
the log n
is also essentially exponential
right something like
the
but it's
but that's also a very unnatural
behavior like
somehow you
it's hard to imagine a problem where
i mean this is more about the analysis
of the algorithm than
the reality of the algorithm
that
there would be a one
just a slightly
super polynomially small fraction of
inputs like a one over n two log and
fraction of inputs
on which you are unable to do anything
and you just
have
exponential running time
you would expect more like a
a situation where if you allow your
algorithm to run
more like you
when you go to higher degrees some
square or you let your mcnc
use more time to mix or
[Music]
so
whatever is the approach that you
are employing
then
as you allow more resources into your
algorithm
the fraction of inputs on which the
algorithm is unable to provide a great
transfer will correspondingly shrink
and there will not be something like
you have to reach exponential time
to get the probability of failure less
than one over
n to the logarithm
whether really
this tail has
power law as required by this definition
it's very strict and uh
sort of
i think even levin will accept that
people will prefer other
definitions but it's not as
[Music]
i would expect that if we actually put
the extra work on
analyzing
how we could trade off
failure probability withdrawing time on
the algorithm
we would see
uh
[Music]
inverse polynomial tails or even steeper
tails that
you know maybe just increase the running
time
to a larger polynomial and you'll
already have an exponentially small
probability of failure
audience looks happy so okay
so um
i was concerned i had too little
material for today but i see that i am
at page
2 of 10.
today
which is great because kind of other
things later can be
sort of skipped or done more quickly
so
but so now that we have these
equivalents
it's possible to talk about algorithms
that make mistakes
decimal when you
when we were just kind of looking at the
expected integral the algorithm or roots
of the running time of the algorithm
there wasn't really a place to talk
about
mistakes
um
so it was sort of a probably not present
in the equation
but when we think of algorithms as
having these sort of two inputs one that
says
what is the input and other that says
so how
picky you are about the quality of uh
the solutions
then it becomes very natural to
incorporate
mistakes
like you could
sort of see
this definition due to impalazzo
he called it a heuristic scheme
to have an algorithm that has again two
inputs
and
the output
may or may not be the correct answer for
x
the running time
is
polynomial
in the length of x
over epsilon
and the probability
that
the output
is not correct
is less than epsilon
so the difference from before
is that before the algorithm knew
when he didn't know the answer it was a
known unknown
here you just allow the algorithm to
answer
something that is completely wrong
and
for example if you look at
a random shot above the threshold
where the goal is to do
refutations
the previous definition is what you want
so you want an algorithm that when it
tells you something you can trust it
but when it says the formula is
unsatisfiable it actually has found the
refutation
and then
there will be inputs on which it's not
able to do it but maybe you can make the
fraction of those inputs smaller and
smaller as you allow more and more
running time
if you have a heuristic scheme for a
preset above the threshold basically you
could just say the formula is
unsatisfiable always
and
except when epsilon is like
exponentially small then you take
exponential time and you
just brute force
threesome
so
countries at about threshold is a
contribution heuristic scheme
but what you're really looking for in
the case it's a algorithm satisfies more
like levin's definition
or at least something is always right
and sometimes knows that he doesn't know
for other problems like
[Music]
stochastic block model type problems
plenty click
trees out below the threshold
this definition is fine like you don't
always have to
uh
well i guess threes are below the
threshold in a way also is like levels
because when you find a satisfying
assignment you know that you have found
the right solution
but for uh
so other optimization problems it's okay
that you find a solution that you cannot
certify that it's good
but just the progressive analysis says
that
it
usually is
and
so those two notions appear to be
um
[Music]
not incomparable but like uh
distinct
that the ps motion is strictly
more powerful and that this seems to be
natural problems like random threes at
about the threshold
for which
the second definition is almost legal to
achieve the first definition is what we
believe to be hard
okay so i guess we have already run into
the time of the
first break what i want to
tell you after the break will be
how we can define a notion of reductions
that will preserve
these definitions of tractability and
also sums definition and
kind of other
reasonable ones
and then we will see if there is enough
time otherwise we'll continue tomorrow
how to get a complete problem like how
to reduce every prominent p under
a large class of distributions to a
particular problem under the uniform
distribution and what data compression
how data compression is used in these
reductions
okay so
i think we can take a break now
so i guess we had a bunch of questions
throughout so maybe we'll just go to
break now and we'll see you in 20
minutes uh at uh
10 to 11.
thanks okay
okay
the schedule is at 15 minutes
yeah we decide we've been
we've been noticing that people
prefer a 20-minute break so
all right
okay of course
okay